mes chers compatriotes
l'heure est grave
la france
elle est au bord du gouffre
alors dans ces circonstances
exceptionnelles
j'ai la grande joie de vous annoncer mon
retour
au cinéma
un peu votre retour au cinéma nicolas
c'est pas le concordat petit de latran
soit donc votre retour au cinéma dans un
film souffre énorme nouvelle je vous
entends je souffre mais je dis que c'est
votre choix généralement je fais ce que
je
connais pas mon professeur je suis pas
neutre il est vrai pas me dire à qui je
suis qui je vous n'avez pas dit je les
dis c'est un mensonge c'est un mensonge
une sélection à lomé pal chic aluminates
heures au
cinéma
si vous voulez
savez pour être président faut être
calme
[Musique]